Transcriber: Anjelika Eda Erdem
Gözden geçirme: Ilayda Gokgoz
Herkese merhaba.
Size bugün bir mucizenin hikayesini
paylaşmak istiyorum.
Bir mucize dünyaya geldi ve dünya değişti.
Ekranda görmüş olduğunuz
biricik kızımız Elif.
Nadir görünen Treacher Collins Sendromu
ile dünyaya geldi.
Ama bu hikayenin farklı bir boyutu var.
Gebeliğin on sekizinci haftası.
Rutin doktor kontrolü: cinsiyetini
öğrenmek için doktora gidiyoruz
ve ultrasonda dudak
yarığı tespit ediliyor.
Bir hafta sonra gidiyoruz.
Damak yarığı tespit ediliyor.
Sonrasında kulakların gelişmediği
de ortaya çıkıyor.
Ve bir ailenin hayatına karşılaşabileceği
en zor sorulardan biri.
Gebeliğe devam mı, tamam mı ?
Bizde normal yaşantımıza
devam ediyorduk.
Toplum tarafından belirlenmiş hedefler
doğrultusunda koşuyorduk.
Özel sektörde yol alıyorduk ama
hayat bazen öyle
virajlar getiriyor ki karşınıza,
çok farklı boyuta geçiyorsunuz.
Konfor alanımızdan vazgeçecektik.
Elif dünyaya gelmeli miydi,
gelmemeli miydi ?
Çevremiz tarafından çokça aksi
yönde görüş bildirildi.
‘İleride mutlu olamaz.’
‘Yaşıtlarıyla konuşamaz.’
‘Bir çok kişi onunla alay eder.’
Bize o sıralar felsefi sorgulamalara
girdik tabi.
Biyolojik açıdan baktık, varoluşsal
açıdan baktık, dedik:
Bir insanın yaşam hakkı kime
göre ve neye göre?
Mutluluğu sadece fiziksel olarak tam
ve bütün bireyler mi hak ediyor?
Ya da bir canlının anne karnının içinde ya
da dışında olmasının bir farkı var mı ?
Hepsini bu zorlu süreçte düşündük.
Ve bir karar almamız gerekiyordu.
O kararı verdik, yolumuza devam ettik.
Hala heyecanlanıyorum.
İlk günkü gibi.
Çünkü çok zor süreçler yaşadık
biz o dönemde, hala da yaşıyoruz.
Bir seçim yaptık ve geri kalan
her şey mühim değildi artık.
Bu yola baş koyacaktık.
Karşılaşacaklarımız neydi
onları da bilmiyorduk.
Uzun, zorlu bir yolculuk bizi bekliyordu.
Elif dünyaya geldi.
Çenenin geride olmasından dolayı kanül,
ekranda gördüğünüz o takıldı.
Konuyla ilgili hiçbir şey bilmiyoruz.
Treacher Collins nedir?
Yüz anomalisi nedir?
Farklı sorunlar nedir?
Bunların hiçbirini bilmiyorduk.
Araştırdık, o süreçte herkesi araştırdık.
Fakat maalesef sağlıklı bir
bilgiye ulaşamadık.
Ve karar verdik.
Ne olursa olsun, bu işin
peşinde gidecektik.
Araştırdım, okudum, ettim
aileleri bulmaya çalıştım
iğneyle kazıya kazıya, yavaş yavaş
o ailelere ulaştık
ve ziyaret etmeye başladık.
Elif 2 ay yoğun bakımda kaldı.
Sonrasında da evde de solunum cihazıyla
yaşamına devam etti.
Aileleri ziyaret ettik.
Ya nedir Treacher Collins?
Ne sorunlar yaşıyorsunuz?
Karşılaştığınız zorluklar nedir?
Bize anlatır mısınız?
Dediler.
Dedim.
Dediler ki: ’Ben çocuğumu arkadaşları alay
etmesin diye parka dahi çıkaramıyorum.
Metrobüse biniyorum,
arkadaşları, insanlar
sizin görüntünüzden rahatsızız.
Lütfen bu metrobüse binmeyin.′
Okullara bu çocukların dış görünüşü
nedeniyle alınmadıklarına şahit olduk.
Hala öyle haylaz, benzer sorunları
toplumda görüyoruz.
Zorlu.
İnsanların hayatlarından utandıkları bir
süreçti ve ben onu, o an bir karar verdim,
ben ne olursa olsun bu işin
peşine düşecektim.
Ne olursa olsun bu çocuklarının yüzünün
gülmesi için mücadele edecektim.
Geri kalan herşeyi bıraktım.
Ailelerle iletişimi kurduk, onların
dertleriyle ilgilendik, paylaştık.
Sonrasında Yüzümle Mutluyum
Derneği’ni kurduk.
Yüzümle Mutluyum Derneği ülkemizde
ilk ve tek dernek kendi alanında.
Doğumsal sendromların yanı
sıra tümör, iz, yanık gibi
çeşitli sebeplerle yüzünde farklılık
olan herkese biz hitap ediyoruz.
Ne mi yaptık?
Bu aileleri bir araya getirdik,
atölye çalışmaları yaptık.
Bu bireylerin en büyük sorunu
içe kapanma, izolasyondu.
Onlara destek olmaya çalıştık.
Rehberler oluşturduk, kılavuzları
oluşturduk, internet sitemizde paylaştık.
Elimizden gelen ne varsa yaptık ve bunu
tamamen biz kendi gönüllü çabamızla
gerçekleştirdik.
Ama şu anlar unutulmazdı.
Benzer süreçleri yaşayan bireyler
ilk defa bir araya geliyordu.
Çoğu yan mahallede birbirini tanımıyor.
Aynı dertleri paylaşıyorlar ama
birbirinden farklılar
ve o an gerçekten unutulmazdı,
bu aileler ilk defa birbirini gördü.
Kendi yaşadıklarını birbirleriyle
paylaşmaya başladılar.
Ve o an benim için,
yani şey vardır ya hani.
Artık ölsem de gam yemem.
O durum olmaya başlamıştı.
Okullara gidiyoruz.
Farkındalık sunumları yapıyoruz.
Akran zorbalığı sunumlarına başladık.
Bunu tamamen kendi imkanlarımızla okul
okul geziyoruz arkadaşlarımızı
yetiştiriyoruz, gönüllerimizde var.
Hep beraber okul okul gezip,
bu farkındalığı artırmayı çalışıyoruz.
Yüz bölgesinde görünür,
ne fark olursa olsun
her insanın adil, eşit bir yaklaşımı
hak ettiğini savunuyoruz biz.
Bu sunumu da ben dün gece hazırladım.
Biraz spontane olsun istedim.
Içindekileri daha rahat paylaşırım diye.
Biraz o günler geldi aklıma,
o yüzden duygulandım.
Derneğimizi kurduk ve bir yola çıktık.
Biz bu bireylere destek olmak istiyoruz.
Biz bu bireylerin yaşamlarında
farkındalık yaratmak istiyoruz.
Biz bu bireylerin toplumla
iç içe olmasını istiyoruz.
Bu misyonu devam ettirirken
geniş tuttuk vizyonumuzla.
Dedik ki, biz uluslararası
anlamda da güzel işler yapalım.
Hemen gittik yurtdışı
bağlantılarımızı kurduk.
Face Equality International,
bizim gibi derneklerin
bir arada çalışmasını
hedefleyen ortak bir ağ.
Oraya üye olduk.
33 ülkeden.
IFHOHYP
İşitme engelliler, gençler için
kurulan bir dernek.
Ve EURORDIS, Avrupa Nadir Hastalıklar Ağı.
Gittik buralarda yüz eşitliğini anlattık.
İngiltere'ye gittik, fon aldık.
İspanya'ya aile ziyaretleri yaptık.
Fransa'ya gittik.
Romanya'ya gittik.
İsviçre'ye gittik.
Hep anlattık.
Yüz eşitliğini anlattık.
Hatta EURORDIS, Avrupa Nadir
Hastalıklar Ağı’nın yüz eşitliğini
biz temsil etmeye başladık.
Ve bir baktık ki bir süre sonra biz
yurtdışında basında yer almaya başlıyoruz.
Bizi örnek kuruluş olarak
göstermeye başlıyorlar.
Başladılar. Bu bizim için çok
gurur verici bir durumdu.
Yüzümle Mutluyum Haftası yaptık.
Kelebek çizdik yüzümüze,
çocuklarımıza.
Ve sokakta yüzünde kelebek ile
insanların gezmelerini istedik.
Sosyal medya etkinliklerini de paylaştık.
Ve müthiş bir empati sağlandı.
Çocuklar, okullarında aktiviteler yaptık.
Çocuklar o güne kadar ihmal edilen,
arka plana atılan çocuklar.
İlk defa okulda
krallar, kraliçeler gibi
karşılanmaya başladılar.
Onların hayatında bir
dönüm noktası yarattık.
Ve bu süreci anlattığım
‘Mucizenin adı Elif’ isimli
kitabı da kaleme aldım bu süreçte.
Bunların hepsi yaşandı, bitti çok kısa
sürede ve hayat devam ediyor.
Biz yüz eşitliği istiyoruz.
Yüz eşitliğini şu an biz Birleşmiş
Milletler gündemine dahi
taşımaya çalışıyoruz.
Nedir yüz eşitliği?
İnsanın yüz görünümü
nasıl olursa olsun
adil ve eşit yaklaşımı
hak ettiği bir bilinç.
Topluma bakıyoruz geçmişten sözlü kültür,
yazılı kültür.
Şu anda da görsel kültür.
Sen yakışıklı olmalısın.
Sen güzel olmalısın ki
bazı işlere alınmalısın.
Yetenekli olmalısın ama dış
görünüş daha önce geliyor.
Biz bu kalıpları yıkmaya çalışıyoruz.
Biz bu ezberleri bozmaya çalışıyoruz.
Bu alanda mücadele veren tek derneğiz.
İşimiz çok zor.
Yel değirmenlerine karşı yarışıyoruz.
Savaşıyoruz.
Dayatılmış ideal dış görünüş kalıplarını
biz parçalamaya çalışıyoruz
ve bunu yapan tek
sivil toplum kuruluşuyuz.
Arkamızda hiçbir destek yok.
Neler yapılmalı?
Okullarda müfredatları bu eğitim
sunumları konulmalı.
İş yerlerinde görünür farklılıkları olan
bireylere daha adil yaklaşım için
kılavuzlar oluşturmalı.
Hayatın her alanında biz yer almalıyız.
Anlatacak çok şey var tabi.
Zorlu, uzun bir yol.
Ben özel sektörde çalışıyorum
aynı zamanda.
İşte önümüze bir yol çıktı,
Elif’i seçtik.
Elif ile devam ettik.
Sonrasında yüzlerce kişiye dokunduk,
ailelere dokunduk.
Dünya çapında ses getiren işler yaptık,
takdir edildik.
Bu süreçte bende de
çok farkındalıklar oldu.
Ben bu zamana kadar.
Hep yalnız adamı oynuyordum.
Konumuz, temamız maske ya.
Dünya benim arkamdaydı,
ben görememiştim.
Bu süreçte çokça da hatalar yaptım.
Bu davaya adarken kendimi, eşimi ihmal
ettiğim, arkadaşlarımı ihmal ettim,
ailemi ihmal ettim.
Bir davaya adadım.
Mutlu muyum? Mutluyum.
Çünkü misyonumu tamamen
bulmuş durumdayım.
Ama şu an burada onlardan herkesin
huzurunda özür diliyorum.
Bana bu süreçte, bu yaşıma kadar gelen
herkese emekleri için de ben
çok teşekkür ediyorum!
Ve şunu söylemek istiyorum,
şunu söylemek istiyorum.
Bu süreçte şunu anladım, kendimi
de daha iyi tanımaya başladım.
Ben bu dünyada ne para istiyorum, ne
pul istiyorum, ne makam istiyorum.
Birine dokunmak, birini sevgi ile
paylaşmak, birini topluma kazandırmak
kadar haz veren, gurur veren
başka bir duygu da yok.
Ben bu dünyada bu çocukların Emre abisi
olarak geçip gitmek istiyorum.
Teşekkür ediyorum.